In TCP congestion control, the senders continue to
increase their rate until they see packet drops
in the network. Packet drops occur because the
senders are sending at a rate that is faster
than the rate at which a particular router
in the network might be able to drain its
buffer. So you might imagine, for example, that
if all three of these senders are sending at
a rate that is equal to the rate at which the router is able to send
traffic downstream, then eventually this buffer will fill
up. TCP interprets packet loss as congestion. And
when senders see packet loss, they slow down
as a result of seeing the packet loss.
This is an assumption. Packet drops are not
a sign of congestion in all networks. For example,
in wireless networks, there may be packet loss
due to corrupted packets as a result of
interference. But in many cases, packet drops do
result, because some router in the network has a
buffer that has filled up and can no
longer hold anymore packets and hence it drops
the packets as they arrive. So senders increase
rates until packets are dropped. Periodically probing the network
to check whether more bandwidth has become available.
Then they see packet loss, interpret that as congestion,
and slow down. So, congestion control has two parts.
One is an increase algorithm, and the other is
a decrease algorithm. In the increase algorithm, the
sender must test the network to determine whether the
network can sustain a higher sending rate. In the
decrease algorithm, the senders react to congestion to achieve
optimal loss rates, delays in sending rates. Let's now talk
about how senders can achieve these increase and decrease algorithms.